Те, що виглядає, як похід на каное, для Костянтина Чикалова
є демонстрацією на його річці Прип'ять.
Подорожі на веслах голова білоруської екологічної групи "Багна"
організовує вже впродовж трьох років.
Він хоче розповісти звичайним білорусам
про незайману природу на Прип'яті й висловити протест
проти водного шляху Є-40, який може тут з'явитись.
Ще з дитинства Костянтин бачить себе захисником тварин і природи.
А для нас річка Прип'ять є своєрідною європейською Амазонкою.
Це місце унікальне, адже люди можуть приїхати сюди
й подивитись, як виглядали річки раніше.
Якою була колись природа в Європі.
Якщо ми це збережемо, ці великі площі дикої природи,
то збережемо також і екологічну рівновагу на європейському континенті.
Є-40 пройде посередині 11 білоруських заповідників
і може зруйнувати цілі еко-системи, кажуть активісти.
Водний шлях має з'єднати Балтійське море з Чорним.
Через середину Полісся - одного з останніх великих болотних районів
із заплавними лісами Європи.
На Поліссі живе 90 відсотків видів птахів Білорусі,
також і ті, яким загрожує вимирання.
Деякі гніздяться прямо на необроблених берегах.
Цього разу маршрут на каное простягнувся на 35 кілометрів.
Саме туди, де річка повинна стати судноплавною.
Деякі місця тут майже непрохідні, навіть для каное.
Поки що великі кораблі зашкодити птахам не можуть.
Група часто зупиняється в прибережних селах.
Там вони розмовляють про запланований канал із жителями.
Часто люди в селах мають лише обмежені джерела інформації.
Таким джерелом можемо бути для них ми.
Щоб вони отримували інформацію не лише від державних медіа,
але й мали власну думку.
Тоді вони можуть вирішувати самі, що для них важливіше:
розвиток водного транспорту чи бажання захистити
своє навколишнє середовище й зберегти його здоровим.
Річка в таких селах як Красава завжди була в центрі життя.
Про запланований проект Є-40 тут до цього часу ще ніхто не чув,
але деякі жителі швидко вбачають в ньому шанс для економічного розвитку регіону.
Водний шлях був би для нас корисним.
Раніше тут вже пропливали човни в Україну.
На річці був інтенсивний рух.
Якщо це матиме негативний вплив на навколишнє середовище, то це - погано.
Зараз води стало менше. Раніше тут можна було вудити рибу.
Тепер річка можна сказати висихає.
Це ж добре. Нехай будють. Тоді тут буде цивілізація,
тоді тут з'явиться більше людей. І стане цікавіше.
І ми зможемо їздити на Чорне море.
Але уряд усе ще шукає інвесторів.
Остаточного рішення про будівництво ще немає.
Тому міністерство транспорту республіки Білорусь
раптово скасовує заплановане інтерв'ю щодо Є-40.
Утім, голова транснаціональної комісії експертів із Є-40
підкреслює переваги водного вантажного транспорту.
Він є екологічно чистим, а наземні маршрути перевантажені вже зараз.
Розвинеться інфраструктура, а з нею і навколишній регіон.
Використати потенціал річки на благо народу є головним завданням уряду.
Другий день подорожі на каноє.
Багато учасників робить це вперше.
Біля табірного вогнища й під час сніданку
Костянтин може розповідати про свої побоювання через Є-40.
Адже він впевнений - Білорусь повиннна розвивати на Прип'яті
радше екологічний туризм, ніж перевезення вантажів.
Людство не думає про те, щоб залишити ці місця незайманими -
лишити їх самій природі.
Тоді б ми приходили сюди, просто спостерігали б за тим,
як співає пташка і як повільно все змінюється.
Еколог побоюється, що будівництво каналу може висушити
тут дикі зарості й болота, що вже відбулось в радянські часи
внаслідок великих програм з осушування.
Адже русло річки необхідно заглибити для великих кораблів.
Прип'ять протікає в Білорусі через зону радіоактивного відчуження,
що утворилась після чорнобильської аварії.
Для природоохоронців, колег Костянтина, - це жахливий урок з минулого.
Адже великих економічний проект може мати руйнівні наслідки
також і для природи на Прип'яті.